florian philippot le vice président du
front national est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
votre partie sa place à leur premier ou
au coup de coude avec l'ump semble
l'enjeu numéro 1 des élections
départementales dont le premier tour se
déroule dimanche toute la campagne
tourne autour de vous avec moi ce soir
pour vous interroger nadège puncak de l'
agence france-presse
notre partenaire comme chaque semaine et
perrine tarneaud de public sénat
pour le patron des sénateurs ump bruno
retailleau le fn fait campagne pour son
parti et pas du tout pour les
départements il a déclaré ce matin est
ce que votre ambition première
effectivement n'est pas de décrocher la
pole position
non notre ambition c'est effectivement
d'incarner l'alternative dans ces
élections départementales je crois même
qu'on est le seul mouvement qui fait
campagne sur les départements et les
politiques des départements
j'ai pas entendu le gouvernement c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire avec monsieur
valls qui parle de tout sauf des
départements et unie l'ump d'ailleurs
quitterait absent du terrain parler de
l'enjeu fondamental et notamment la
survivance là sur eux l'existence même
du département voilà cette collectivité
celui ci est d'autre part tous les
candidats de l'ump du ps sur le fil le
français lui il souhaite que le
département existe demain comme
collectivité de proximité
on sait qu'il est menacé par la réforme
territoriale bien sûr la loi nôtre et
qui fixe comme horizon des grosses
régions qui sont prévues qui sont déjà
actés les grosses régions fusionnée qui
seront très lointaine qui seront très
coûteuses et le département lui il est
menacée à l'horizon 2020 on s'est même
par monsieur da silva ac est le patron
des socialistes de l'essonne le
suppléant monsieur valls que le
département il nous a dit il disparaîtra
à moyen terme
voilà nous on se bat dans cette campagne
départementale d'abord pour que le
département existe parce qu'on pense que
s'il n'existe plus alors des millions de
français dans la ruralité dans les
petites villes aussi disparaîtront
sortiront des écrans radar des
politiques publiques notamment les
politiques de leur dit d'arrêter mais on
en reparlera effectivement on en
reparlera avec nadège tout à l'heure on
ira plus avant dans
dans votre campagne pour les
départements donc pour les sauver dites
vous qui peut penser que madame le pen
incarne l'alternance vous dites que vous
voulez incarner l'alternative est bien
nicolas sarkozy lance cette phrase ce
matin dans nice matin elle incarne non
pas l'alternance mais une colère et le
surf sur une souffrance elle ne
construit rien seule l'ump peut changer
vraiment les choses assure son président
pour qui voter fn ou voter ps
c'est l'assurance que rien ne change
enfin il ressasse nicolas sarkozy je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'il change de
disque irsa sears hassidique soit la
même chose je n'avance pas qui peut
croire que nicolas sarkozy incarne le
changement
nicolas sarkozy a été au pouvoir pendant
dix ans ministre de l'intérieur puis
président de la république il avait la
possibilité de tout changer il s'est
fait élire sur des presses des promesses
assez précise quand même en 2007
je le rappelle un limitation de
l'immigration plus d'ordre le kärcher
je vais pas m'arrêter de rappeler tout
mais schengen qu'on devait réformer
redonner du pouvoir aux français par
rapport à l'europe
le travail le pouls le président du
pouvoir d'achat la valeur travail
on a vu ce qu'il en a fait c'était une
catastrophe absolue la dette a même
explosé de 600 milliards sous son mandat
il n'a pas réduit l'immigration le
karcher s'est transformé en vaporisateur
et rien n'a changé donc nicolas sarkozy
me paraît griller dans la vie et je
précise et pas simplement un retour raté
je pense qu'il est démodé ont
véritablement des mots doux à l'oreille
et je précise que dans la troisième
partie pour le co tout à l'heure avec
perrine on abordera votre programme
national sur lequel on a beaucoup de
questions à vous poser il ya un autre
angle d'attaqué contre vous qui est
développé par manuel valls
outre l'impasse économique et social
avec qui il a évoqué hier soir dans
l'essonne c'est la stigmatisation et si
ce choix du premier ministre se révèle
contre productifs est ce que vous avez
demandé la tête du premier ministre mais
évidemment déjà je remarque vous me
citez sénateur ump sarkozy ils valent
ces gens là ne font que critiquer le
front national il parle peu de leurs
projets leurs propositions et leurs
programmes
c'est quand même la première chose qu'on
peut noter sont obsédés tous par le
front national ça c'est l'horaire faveur
c'est leur problème ce sont leurs leur
obsession à votre avantage
ça prouve qu'on est centre de gravité de
la vie politique française parce que le
tête parce qu'on est les seuls à lancer
des grands débats de fou c'est vrai si
on n'était pas là on parlerait quand
même de beaucoup moins de choses dans la
vie politique française sur les sujets
de fond comme l'europe l'islamisme
cité ou bien d'autres on pourrait
revenir également pour répondre à cette
question ad'abord la part d'un premier
ministre excusez moi mais l'emploi du
terme
je revendique de stigmatiser un parti
politique et donc qu'ils le veuillent ou
non les 30 % d'électeurs qui s'apprête à
voter pour lui
les millions de français de ses
compatriotes à lui qui sont qui croient
aux idées du front national qui sont
patriotes et qui votent pour lui c'est
juste inadmissible c'est pas à la
hauteur c'est pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'on attend d'un chef de gouvernement
on aura appris au moins pendant cette
campagne et c'était intéressant de
l'avoir appris que manuel valls n'est
pas un homme d'état et c'est jean marc
ayrault donc son prédécesseur qui a
raison car il reproche finalement à
manuel valls de vous avoir mis au centre
de la campagne d'été par devoir de vous
donner raison
oui jean marc ayrault chance a bien vu
de ce point de vue là effectivement mais
est ce qui veut dire en creux et je
pense qu'on sera d'accord avec lui c'est
que manuel valls n'est pas un homme
d'état il n'est pas à la hauteur delà de
ce qu'on attend d'un homme d'état j'ai
cru comprendre qu'il visait des
fonctions encore plus élevé j'ai envie
de lui dire faut arrêter tout de suite
parce que vous n'êtes pas au niveau
quand on marque comme seul message
apporté au pays d'abord de stigmatiser
et de revendiquer ce terme une partie de
son propre peuple
on n'est pas au niveau c'est le parti
qui l'a visée d'accord est votre
programme très bien il faut pas être
idiot quand on quand on stigmatise comme
il le dit lui-même un parti politique on
stigmatise de fait les électeurs qui
vont avec
ainsi que les dizaines de milliers
d'adhérents militants candidats etc
deuxièmement je viens monsieur valls
effectivement c'est impliqués dans cette
campagne et la nationaliser et donc il
devra en tirer les conséquences et de
responsabilité donc mais elle devra
partir son objectif c'est que le fn soit
bas et que le ps soit aux assisses est
tout d'un verre sert si le ps est bas
avec le fn est haut
il devra partir au moulin on ne peut pas
tout espérer
ceci sera votre message de dimanche soit
en matinée si sa campagne était un
succès pour l'instant ce n'est pas le
cas bon et si effectivement demain le fn
était bas et le ps très haut
vous imaginez bien que ce qu'il dirait
il dirait tout petit c'est grâce à moi
c'est grâce à mon implication bon en
revanche si c'est un échec
il doit en tirer les mêmes conclusions
ce sera aussi de son fait
vous avez autre il devra être
responsable tout cas moi j'ai été choqué
le fait du fait de voir françois
hollande dire avant même l'élection quoi
qu'il se passe rien ne changera je
trouve que celle à linverse de la
démocratie l' inverse de ce qu on attend
là aussi d'un responsable politique
bref il ya eu beaucoup de médiocrité
dans cette campagne beaucoup
d'énervement
beaucoup même de chez vous aussi de la
méthode non je crois pas du tout on a
évoqué sur qu'un candidat et on a essayé
peu reluisant reconnaissez le cnra page
c'est tout un assist homophobes que nous
avons condamné mais qui sont tout à fait
marginaux numérique et manger on s'en
aller jusqu'à l'exclusion suisse seront
exclus ils seront exclus bien sûr
numériquement
c'est très marginal ça existe dans tous
les mouvements si on prend la peine de
chercher on en trouve partout mais on en
a déjà cité plusieurs à l'ump et au ps
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire mais on a
essayé d'élever le niveau sur le fond
sur les grands enjeux je vous parlais du
département des politiques publiques en
falloir vous citiez l'islam y en a eu on
a eu quand même excusez moi je veux
juste la phrase un tour en de médiocrité
de la part du notamment de monsieur
valls qui s'est énervé qui n'est pas
capable de garder ses nerfs qui n'est
pas capable d'être serein et qui n'est
plus capable de faire ça fond d'un cul
d'occuper sa fonction quand est-ce qu'il
a le temps de travailler d'être premiers
ministres de s'occuper des vrais
problèmes des vraies préoccupations des
français le chômage et le reste quand il
ya juste un an
j'avoue conseil des ministres jeudi il y
aura un texte sur le renseignement pour
renforcer les outils de la police
est-ce que vous approuver ces mesures
qui vont permettre donc en fait à nos
agents d'utiliser dans la légalité
certains outils électroniques pour donc
essayer de prévenir des attentats
un qu'ils utilisent déjà hors de toute
légalité
c'est une loi qui ne nous impressionne
pas parce qu'elle se concentre si vous
voulez sur les communications
télécommunication internet
bon c'est un aspect du sujet j'ai le
sentiment que le gouvernement cartonne
internet parce que il a la capacité
d'agir parce que tu écris par pas
vraiment là il s'agit d'aller voir les
sms les données de l'internet l'âge et
l'organisation des véhicules voilà mais
on reste dans ce domaine des
communications télécommunication parce
qu'on a le progrès technique pour le
faire donc on sait faire à peu près et
encore puis on a déjà vu que cinq sites
ont été retirés pour la première fois
qu'est un dessin qui se retrouve
immédiatement sur une page facebook dans
son intégralité donc on voit que même
techniquement c'est loin d'être au point
mais d'abord ça pose un problème on ne
peut pas se limiter dans une politique
de lutte contre le terrorisme à internet
aux communications télécommunication
avec ça puisqu'il ya eu des embauches
que peu d'annoncés juste marie d'accord
sciences humaines mais il faut aller sur
le dur des problèmes au bout d'un moment
une politique c'est aussi par exemple
d'avoir des frontières mais ça c'est du
concret c'est dur
réel de savoir qui rendre sur son
territoire de maîtriser les trafics
d'armes deuxième un grand avantage de
schengen dit le ministre de l'intérieur
grâce à shen hui l avons des
informations sur les fils transit c'est
formidable ça c'est vraiment renverser
la situation grâce à gilles games
enchères une gaine son système
d'information serait sourd et aveugle
d'hibernation
c'est vrai que sans frontières on est on
est sourd et aveugle donc c'est à cause
de schengen qu'on est sourd et aveugle
je crois qu'il est c'est l'inversé on
vous avez vu que les leaders européens
de l'intérieur ont décidé de renforcer
les contrôles sur le pourtour de l'année
chaque total on vient d'apprendre le
coller sur les deux premiers mois de
2000 15 l'exclu l'immigration
clandestine avait explosé de 250% vers
l'union européenne on convient que
frontex et schengen c'est un échec
absolu qu'il faut avoir des frontières
et l'argent revient aux durs à avoir des
frontières réarmer notre état nos forces
de police de gendarmerie de
renseignement le renseignement était
très accablé par la politique
d'austérité depuis des années sous
sarkozy puisse wall ans il a perdu
beaucoup de moyens et beaucoup
d'effectifs et ça n'est pas restaurée et
puis le dur c'est de lutter contre le
terreau de cet islamisme et donc de ce
terrorisme notamment le communautarisme
ils recrutent dans le communautarisme
les dérives communautaristes et puis
l'autre terreau c'est notre politique
étrangère qui est absurde
on ne peut pas continuer d'avoir les
meilleures relations du monde avec les
puissances comme le qatar ou l'arabie
saoudite qui finance en sous-main
l'islamisme et le terrorisme ici alors
là ça c'est une politique globale
là on se contente on va pas gérer le
terrorisme sur un clavier sur un clavier
un décret portant pas suffisant et que
l'endoctrinement se fait sur les sites
internet vous le savez non non c'est
souvent un complément mais ça fait aussi
une mosquée généralement qu'on doit
combat surveillées dont on sait qu
surveiller les drêches nous ya un réseau
il ya des hommes qui a duré il ya un cul
du web un site internet et on voit
comment internet est utilisé aujourd'hui
les réseaux sociaux par le groupe etat
islamique vous l'avez vu pour propager
ses idées épouvantable et le ministre de
l'intérieur justement a interdit cinq
premiers sites et
le ministre de l'intérieur considère que
vous n'aimez pas la république car
certains parcours fut certains nous
refuse son synonyme d'affaiblissement de
la france face au terrorisme ou ou
condamnés toujours l'interdiction de
certains sites islamistes donc on a une
pas l'interdiction de certains sites
islamistes on dit qu on est attaché aux
libertés numériques qu'il faut même les
sacraliser parce que autant je lui ciblé
quelques sites bien sûr ça existait déjà
avant ça existe ou demain un peu plus
s'il faut les croire mieux la meilleure
solution ce n'est pas de désintérêt mais
d'accord mais moi je voudrais pas qu au
passage on en profite pour faire une
sorte de patriot act comme on dit c'est
à dire une surveillance généralisée ou
un jour on commencera par les sites
le terroriste puis quelques années plus
tard on ira sur d'autres sphères et ce
sera finalement tout ce qui dérange tout
ce qui n'est pas dans la ligne qui sera
plus ou moins de museler interdit
surveiller et ça posera un problème donc
je dire il faut mettre des garde-fous
quand même il y en a vous savez dans la
loi relative
ça ne s'amuse ça ne suffit pas une haute
autorité administrative soit disant
indépendante on voit que les autorités
en france ne sont jamais totalement
indépendante faut pas se leurrer il faut
que la justice soit là on peut pas
exclure totalement la justice de ce
processus notamment j'ai appris qu'on ne
l'utiliserai davantage une balise
d'interception de proximité comme ils
disent
qui peut capter tous vos sms vos
communications téléphoniques dans des
dizaines voire des centaines de mètres
alentours
là ça pose un problème il faut que ce
soit extrêmement surveillé ce genre que
vous n'approuvez pas ce texte qui vient
au concédant j'ai dit sur les rangs
selon vous la pro b pas besoin de vous
seriez cela prouve s'il ya les
garde-fous il y a des garde-fous jury
des j'aurais surtout à prouver s'il y
avait eu un une politique globale comme
lady sur le dur les frontières
l'immigration et le communautarisme
notamment alors le maire ump de châlons
sur saône a décidé de supprimer le menu
de substitution dans les cantines
scolaires de sa ville le jour où il ya
du porc est ce que vous approuvez
cette décision qui est condamnée par la
ministre de l'éducation nationale oui se
passent leur vie à condamner à
invectivé faudrait qu'il fasse autre
chose les ministres si en france un qui
travaille un petit peu notamment dans
l'éducation nationale a beaucoup de
travail
najat vallaud belkacem si elle veut
alors là vous approuvez cela non mais je
dis qu'un maire est libre de faire ce
qu'il veut qu'une cantine scolaire n'a
pas à s'intéresser à la religion que son
seul critère j'ai envie de dire ah bah
c'est l'axé social et le deuxième
critère c'est l'équilibré à l'ami
alimentaire pour les enfants pour qu'ils
mangent correctement au moins un repas
par jour alain candelas par exemple ce
jour-là à chalon le petit musulman il va
il pourra pas manger non mais c'est pas
la cantine scolaire de s'adapter
voilà si ça peut exister dans certaines
villes si ça existe et que le maire
décide que ça n'existe pas ça existe si
ça n'existe pas rit souvent je vais vous
dire ou alors devient franchement vous
approuvez mais il fait ce qu'il veut
oui je la procession il fait ça d'accord
il fait ce qu'il veut je veux dire au
bout d'un moment mais je ne sais pas
quelles sont ses motivations réelles
mais yat il faut pas se leurrer
éventuellement les points quand la
cantine scolaire aujourd'hui souvent
vous avez déjà de trois menus de cantine
se sont modernisés mais même pas pour
des questions religieuses tout
simplement parce que ça permet pour les
conseillers des enfants dégoût difficile
parfois qui a des allergies etc donc
dégoût pour tout le monde et il faudrait
il faut veiller à l'équilibré
alimentaire à la cantine parce que
aujourd'hui menu substitution demain
horaires de substitution pour les pistes
dans les piscines entre hommes et femmes
en séparera ou comme on l'a déjà fait
dans certaines villes puis jours fériés
de substitution comme on l'a fait on l'a
voté outre-mer c'est dans la loi macron
on supprime certains ont remplacé retint
jours fériés traditionnel français par
des jours fériés religieux et puis loi
de substitution voilà c'est ça
l'engrenage du communautarisme et moi je
veux pas je veux la république je veux
la laïcité et je veux pas le
communautaire alors nadège déjà que va
arriver maintenant donc on va voir
quelles sont donc vos arguments pour
l'élection qui se joue dimanche et la
semaine prochaine on voit cela est
d'abord on s'est interrogé sur d'autres
motivations peut être extra
départemental de votre parti pour cette
élection celle enquête signée jérôme
rabier c'est une image dont le front
national rêve dont de nombreux cantons
laurent lopez est pour l'instant
l'unique le seul conseiller général à
porter l'étiquette fn
mais au soir du 29 mars cela va sans nul
doute changé comme l'espère marine le
pen nous atteindrons un seuil fracasse
celui qui permettra la qualification de
nombre de nos candidats au second tour
et nous saurons les maîtres de
l'élection alors que le front national
se veut premier parti de france dans les
urnes
il l'est déjà en nombre de candidats
1912 binôme présent dans 93% des cantons
loin devant ses adversaires
une nouveauté pour un parti longtemps
déficit d'implantation locale le front
national est donné vraiment une force
politique nationale c'est vraiment le
front national il est présent partout et
le montrer à travers cette présence
qu'au fond à la fois il n'a plus de
problème de vivier de candidats et
continuer à tisser son réseau local qui
lui a été jusqu'à présent assez
bénéfique dans la lignée des municipales
le fn veut transformer l'essai mais dans
une élection peu favorable à son
isolement sur l'échiquier politique le
parti sait qu'il sera difficile
d'enlever des départements c'est dans
l'aisne le var et le vaucluse que repose
son plus grand espoir de l'emporter mais
loin de s'enflammer
les frontistes se fixe un objectif plus
que raisonnable si nous passant la barre
des 20% alors nous allons être présents
dans un nombre spectaculaire de second
tour
sous-estimer son score 10 points sous
les sondages qui placent le front
national autour des 30%
une stratégie qui lui permettra d'être
au centre du jeu au soir des résultats
en fixant un objectif raisonnable en
termes de pourcentages voir en terme de
conquête de département et bien marine
le pen est à peu près sûr certaines ne
pas être démenti dimanche soir et
d'apparaître véritablement comme la
gagnante de ce premier tour des
départementales mais en réalité c'est
bien le statut de premier parti de
france que le fn espère conforter pour
prolonger la lancée des européennes et
se concentrer sur les futures échéances
électorales qui seront les régionales en
décembre et la présidentielle en 2017
voilà alors on le voit dans les sondages
et puis dans le sujet combien de
regarder apparemment vous allez gagner
beaucoup d'élus danse et départementales
l'ambiance était à l'euphorie au front
national n'ont pas l'euphorie non
l'ambiance est à l'optimisme c'est vrai
on est en tout cas sur le terrain on se
bat on fait campagne on bat campagne et
on espère avoir un maximum d'élus
départementaux d'ailleurs on en appelle
à la participation la plus large
possible parce qu'on nous vend depuis
des jours et des jours une forte
abstention comme si on l'a souhaité nous
ne disons rien n'est fait voyez le mal
partout
si je sors de plusieurs débats houleux
première question c'est est pourquoi il
y aura-t-il une forte abstention et on
n'en sait rien avec les sondages les
années quelque chose et c'est risqué
donc ce n'est pas fait j'allais un peu
décidé d'aller voter alors qu'il avait
fait le choix de ne pas voter jusqu'à
philippe sauvage et sa forte en europe
et pour cent vous annonçons annonce 30%
pour le f cell et là on vient de voir
marine le pen qui nous parle de labarde
20% pourquoi ce décalage parce que on a
fait le calcul
une bonne surprise pour vous donner
l'impression de n'en avoir une bonne
surprise
on a eu le ferait vraiment soit visible
dimanche soir non on a fait nos calculs
si au lait à partir de la barre de 20 %
au niveau national on sait qu'on
provoque un maximum de second tour voilà
souvent duel parce qu'il y aura
peut-être pas beaucoup de triangulaires
souvent duels mais en tout cas beaucoup
de second tour et c'est important bien
sûr pour et bien déjà
peut-être que ça éliminera notamment le
parti socialiste le beaucoup de second
tour et puis ça nous permettra d'avoir
des victoires ensuite au second je
reviens juste aussi sur un point il sort
le premier parti de france c'est tard de
toute façon nous serons le premier parti
de france c'est parce que abbas et le
fleurissement est ce qu'on disait non
parce que je pour nous mettre parfois
dans certains sondages devant à quelques
points près ils sont obligés d'agréger
vous avez remarqué l'ump udi divers
droite c'est parfois même plusieurs
candidats le mpd
idei partir ensemble dont 97% soit même
en divers droite c'est-à-dire des
candidats plusieurs candidats dans un
même canton qu'on met dans un même
agrégats donc moi je dis qu'est ce qui
sera d'ailleurs annoncé sur les chaînes
de télévision dimanche soir
parce que si on agrège tous là c'est un
accord ils sont ensemble par un parti
sans cela c'est pas un parti voilà le
front national lui par sous ses propres
couleurs
lila 7650 compte de résultat au
départemental monsieur philippe ou
est-ce que ça préfigure de bons
résultats en 2010 est déjà avant 2017
dont il ya les départementales on verra
ce que ça donne rien n'est fait pour
l'instant on n'est pas une personne qui
a voté donc enfin rien et fun vous avez
l'air très non non on va optimiser jeudi
jusque autorités n'ont ju on n'est pas
euphorique vraiment je pense qu'on est
on est toujours là toujours la tête
froide
mais contrairement à monsieur valls on
garde nos nerfs nous on voit là on est
des gens sérieux
on travaille et en même temps on vise un
maximum d'élus départementaux
avant cela avant 2017 sera ensuite les
régionales et régionales
c'est à dire qu'on partira clairement à
la conquête des régions notamment qui
lui fait qu'un mode de scrutin qui
permet d'envisager plusieurs victoires
alors attendant sa grosse nouvelle
région à vous nous dites que vous ne
vivez pas de département non non et non
et c'est ça je voudrais vous poser comme
question parce que bon on a bien compris
vous venez de tout de suite passer à
l'étape suivante les régionales vous
espérer remporter dans le tiroir et 2017
mais avant il ya les régionales c'est
vrai c'est vrai mais moi je voudrais
revenir au départemental alors vous
allez avoir beaucoup d'élus 20% points
de pourcent verra bien ce qu'il faut
c'est gagner pour avoir vraiment le
pouvoir dans les départements gagnés les
présidences des départements qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que vous allez faire des
alliances avec l'ump ce que vous vous
pensez pouvoir en faire parce que
nicolas sarkozy a été très ferme sur la
question
celui qui fait une alliance ayew est il
exclu du parti
maintenant on vise pas d'alliance avec
l'ump ni à quiconque bon son et quand
vous allez faire alors pour les
présidences des partis avec lesquels
nous ne partageons pas de valeur du
projet pour la france
non nous nous lorsqu'il y aura une
majorité majorité relative dans les
départements et que le front aura des
élus et bien après le second tour donc
quand les élus auront été à peine parler
ses missions voilà et ce sera donc le
troisième à ces vautours exactement
l'élection des présidents et des
exécutants grand marchandage
non justement on va éviter on va pas
faire du marchandage nous
nous on ira sur le fond du projet sert
qu'on aura une petite charte de cinq ou
six maximum engagement de fonds sur les
compétences départementales par exemple
ne pas augmenter les impôts
départementaux pendant toute la durée du
mandat comme on le fait dans nos villes
et même plusieurs de nos villes qui l'on
a déjà et la preview qui les ont déjà
baissé personne il faut qu'il fasse la
même chose dans leur ville
parce que il augmente les impôts locaux
dans leur ville nous on les baisse et
comme on l'a fait à hénin-beaumont déjà
15% de baisse la taxe d'habitation ça
c'est du concret ensuite par exemple
développer la pas pour les personnes
âgées les politiques de solidarité plus
de protection et donc de sécurité dans
les collèges qui ça relève aussi
mollement dans tout le monde sera
gagnant un point les crêpes whaou lundi
1 1 point très politique la survie du
département par rapport à l'engagement à
se battre pour la survie du département
comme collectivité de proximité c'est
alors passe quasi en 2009
voilà les attendait et on proposera
cette charte est si bas il ya des élus
pour faire une majorité avec nous on
proposera tout le monde
et bien tant mieux ça permettra
d'améliorer non ça permettra d'améliorer
le quotidien des habitants et les
français tant mieux dans un département
s'ils veulent pas by feront leur
tambouille mps comme d'habitude ensemble
mais ils prendront leur responsabilité
devant les français devant les électeurs
nous on aura proposé un mieux en tout
cas pour la vie quotidienne à ça on
constate quand même que vous dites que
voulait pas augmenter les impôts mais en
même temps vous allez améliorer la
situation pour les personnes âgées pour
les jeunes pour en fait nous avez un
prono renforcer les services publics de
proximité
vous allez faire aller trop d'argent ou
parce que vous oubliez un point de notre
projet qui s'appelle les connaître les
gabegies les équipes faire des économies
suffira pas à attendre sinon c'est tout
ce que vous annoncez semaine en
renforcement des aides sociales vous
avez eu que la cour des comptes a montré
que 80 % des dépenses de fonctionnement
des départements 80% ce sont les aides
sociales que vous voulez renforcée non
mais on veut notamment aider les
familles face à la dépendance développer
l'aide à domicile par exemple la
domotique les méthodes mais les voilà
finalement la bernique mans sur des
économies et bien des icônes rails en a
peut être augmentée les amener dans nos
villes on a démontré qu'on pouvait faire
cela sans augmenter les impôts je vous
dire des économies on a quand même pas
mal
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
postes superflu en période de crise et
d'austérité par exemple la communication
je suis pas sûr qu'on ait besoin d'un
budget de communication dans un
département aujourd'hui
par exemple les effectifs c'est pas rien
comme dépenses les effectifs ont ça a
explosé avec la décentralisation mais
pas seulement on avait sanctionné
territoriaux par les départs en retraite
on peut mieux gérer les effectifs à
arrêter la croissance des effectifs a
duré assez vite parce que là où ça va
assez vite on est quand même dans une
période de papy boom ou de mamie boom
d'ailleurs souvent et il se trouve que
on peut aller assez vite de ce point de
vue là 3 la lutte contre la fraude au
rsa est une des principales fraude en
france elle n'est pas véritablement
mener la lutte par exemple sur la
question de la fosse domiciliation
dissimulation de revenus non respect des
engagements d'insertion on sait qu'il ya
plusieurs manières de fraude et il faut
y aller faut pas craindre de je ne sais
quelle explosion sociale à tel ou tel
endroit parce que on dérangerait un
système frauduleux non il faut y aller
il faut aller au coeur parce que la
fraude c'est un vol est un vol par
rapport à ceux qui en ont vraiment
besoin aux plus nécessiteux et aux plus
méritants
et puis il ya beaucoup de choses on a
externalisé certains services il ya des
entreprises qui ont travaillé là dessus
qu'ils sont rendu compte que quand on ré
internaliser coûte moins cher il faut
faire la même chose dans les
collectivités départementales voilà
beaucoup de postes d'économies possibles
en même temps je vous dire le seul vote
utile dans cette élection
on a bien vu l'hystérie gouvernementale
ce sera le vote front national
rassemblement bleu marine on a bien vu
que l'ump est et en dehors des écrans
radar l'ump est complice mais parce que
le gouverneur de travail aucune manière
le craindre
le gouvernement ne craint en aucune
manière le score de l'ump ça ne
m'intéresse absolument pas vous croyez
que les attendez attendez il ya quand
même en revanche je mette à 30 mais je
crois même qu'ils aient un sondage qui
met l'ump devant vous à faire du figaro
non c'était la rentrée mais celle-ci
harris interactive qui placent l'ump est
alors qu'on tombe dans la petite arnaque
que je vous disais c'est pas si vous
avez regardé le détail c'était ump plus
unie plus divers droite donc plusieurs
comptes candidat dans un même canton
qu'on agrégé dans un résultat et avec
tout cela il passait un tout petit peu
dérangé fait même résultat qu'à cause si
vous êtes derrière
non mais ça c'est pas les mêmes
candidats donc ils pourront pas avoir
deux candidats au second tour donc on
voit que ça ne leur soit pas bon vous en
donniez c'est ce soir non je suis fier
d'être le premier parti de france d'une
manière il écouter raconter cela mais
alors ce qu'ils veulent mais je finis
juste voir sur la photo jr puisque vous
êtes un parti avec qui on peut pas
passer de compromis non mais ceux qui
veulent mettre une petite fessée
électorale à manuel valls c'est pas les
quelques pas de fessées ça va être
interdite bah justement celle ci les
banques
interdite par le conseil de l'europe la
fessée électoral onpe encore la faire on
peut se permettre ça et bien c'est pas
en votant ump
je crois qu'ils auront compris ça bon
c'est en votant front national en
revanche on le mettra dans un niveau d
angoisse et on lui on le fera
cauchemarder c'est pas plus mal
je crois qu'il mérite ça aujourd'hui le
premier ministre donc je pense que et en
même temps c'est un vote utile pour
sauver le département c'est le seul vote
clair parce que l'ump on connaît pas
bien leur position sur le département
je pense qu'ils sont plutôt pour sa
disparition comme le ps au moins le
front national il a dit les choses
clairement il est pour la survie du
département
en revanche il ne veut pas des grosses
régions coûteuse il souhaite même que
les régions les plus d'élus propres
voilà alors on fera des économies
nationales philippe on imaginer
départements présidés géré par vous même
le fn
la première mesure que vous prenez c'est
quoi je pense c'est la toute première
pour être honnête ce sera un audit
financier pour savoir où on en est il
faut être sérieux
je pense qu'ensuite il faudra lancer un
signal clair sur les politiques de
solidarité notamment vis-à-vis de nos
personnes âgées
on a parlé de du reste à charge pour les
familles concernant la dépendance
on a parlé du maintien à domicile le
montant de l'apa pourra essayer de le
revaloriser au cas par cas il faudra
regarder parce qu'effectivement il ya
des budget derrière mais je pense que
les personnes âgées aujourd'hui qui sont
un peu les oubliés du grand âge j'ai vu
qu'elle manifestait d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui elle les retraités les
petits retraités souffrent de plus en
plus de cette politique d'austérité et
vont souffrir demain ce camp bruxelles
nous annonce que on va ajouter 30
milliards d'euros qu'elles demandent 30
milliards d'euros d'austérité en plus
d'ici 2017
en plus des 50 milliards déjà programmée
il faut bien que quelqu'un paye et 30
mesures d'austérité quelques impairs les
vrais amis l'armée les vieux les jeunes
vous marier et tout le monde m'a les
services publics ou même vous ne devez
pas comment vous payez cela ce que vous
annoncez mais nous ne la zone et laval
avait des désaccords ami est la traque
aux fraudeurs
ça ne suffira pas mais je veux bien sûr
que si ça suffit dans les départements
la liste des économies que je vous ai
fait je vous ai fait au moins cinq ou
six communications
non je venais fait cinq ou six postes
d'économies qui sont considérables qui
sont considérables et en face ne vont
pas nous parlons pas de dépenses non ne
dépense incommensurable ou insurmontable
et bien sûr que tout cela est cadré
département par les comics département
et déjà avec le poids des prestations
sociales qu'elles versent aujourd'hui
les départements sert quasiment
uniquement à ça aujourd'hui mais parce
que le département parfois et sous
on n'a pas fait cet effort d'économies
qui doit faire sur la mauvaise dépense
publique pour favoriser la bonne dépense
publique c'est une question de
réallocation de la dépense publique mais
concernant les 30 milliards d'euros
d'austérité nous disons que ce système
est stupide on va en parler alors je
voudrais savoir quel département parce
que ça on n'a toujours pas dit quel
département vous pensez pouvoir
rattraper
moi ça en laisse les les
projectionnistes du vous avez un plan là
dans la tête vous savez exactement quel
nom collectif avait pas de plans sur les
rives victoire du front national parce
que les français vont voter notre but
c'est de voir un maximum d'élus
départementaux et si on a un ou
plusieurs départements ce sera la cerise
sur le gâteau parce qu'aujourd'hui je
rappelle qu'on a qu'un seul sortant sur
toute la france sur quatre mille élus
voilà donc la marche est très haute
comment ça se passe il faut que les
français sont enfin dépend de quand ça
se passe au front national est ce que
les élus ont toute latitude pour décider
au niveau local ce qu'ils veulent faire
ou bien est-ce que c'est un parti
centraliser le sommet dit à la base
voilà ce qu'il faut faire
non non non merde on prend l'exemple de
nos maires de villes de plus de 10 mille
habitants ils sont c'est la libre
administration des mairies front
national comme partout ailleurs est
d'ailleurs un sondage a démontré qu'ils
étaient cramés oui 73%
si c'était mauvais on parlerait que de
ça pendant une demi-heure dit aussi
qu'il arrive que les électeurs ne se
déjuge pas filer oui mais est comparée
aux villes de même taille gérés par le
nps c'est moins bon 73% chez nous sont
satisfaits de leur maire 66% dans les
villes ump s 74 estiment que l'argent
est bien géré ses 59 % dans les villes
mais voulait pas nous dire quel est le
département où vous vivez en premier bah
je le connais parce que je trouve que
c'est bien comme résultat d'avoir au
bout d'un an nous allons la caisse une
mission sur le département je les avais
pas eu je n'aime pas madame irma vois je
peux pas d'accord merci nadège le ps et
l'ump en tous les cas
semble incapable de trouver la parade
face à la progression du front national
là vous serez d'accord terrain philippot
samia de sheer enquêter dans ces deux
parties pour savoir comment localement
mais pas seulement chercher la parade et
avec quels arguments face à la vague
bleu marine annoncé au départemental le
parti socialiste contre attaque
il ya d'abord eu l'alertent lancé la
semaine dernière par manuel valls
j'ai peur oh mon pays j'ai peur qu'il se
fracasse face contre le front national
un discours repris en boucle par les
responsables nationaux du parti
mais pour elsa di méo l'enjeu est aussi
d'agir au niveau local sa ville de
fréjus est aujourd'hui dirigé par le
front national
elle a participé à l'élaboration d'un
livre est envoyé à tous les candidats
socialistes
un document censé leur servir d'outil
pour contrer point par point le
programme est le bilan du parti de
marine le pen prenant l'exemple de
fréjus des baisses de près de 20 % des
budgets scolaires par enfants n'ont pas
de budget fantaisiste mais de budget qui
très directement impact le quotidien des
écoliers dans les écoles de ma ville
qu'est ce que ça veut dire demain pour
des départements dirigés par le front
national
les réduction drastique des budgets des
collégiens par exemple ça veut dire
également la suppression d'un certain
nombre de services
j'entendais hier marine le pen
d'ailleurs dire qu'elle était prête à
supprimer la gratuité des livres dans
les collèges si les socialistes veulent
mettre la montée du fn au centre du
débat
l'ump semble vouloir faire l' inverse
pour eric doligé coordonnateur aux
élections départementales la meilleure
stratégie contre le front national c'est
de ne pas en parler
nous nous battons pas contre les autres
bateaux pour défendre nos idées sur le
terrain
donc on n'occulte pas mais on n'a pas à
parler toujours des autres on doit
parler de soi on doit parler de ses
projets on doit parler de sa politique
et on n'est pas là pour faire la
promotion des autres mais à l'ump
certains aimeraient que leur parti soit
plus offensif face au front national
inquiet de voir le fn arrivait au second
tour dans tous les cantons de son
département le sénateur gérard longuet a
écrit à tous ses électeurs retrait de
l'euro instrumentalisation de
l'immigration il
clic pourquoi le vote fn conduirait
selon lui à la catastrophe et mes
convictions personnelles
j'aime beaucoup l'ump mais je ne me sens
pas obligé de penser comme l'ump à tout
moment et j'ai voulu écrire par moi même
parce que je ne voulais pas
dire autre chose que ma conviction
profonde conviction profonde c'est que
le front national ne donne aucune chance
de réussite à notre pays une
décrédibilisation du front national
validé par la plupart des économistes
pour qui les applications du programme
du parti ne ferait qu'aggraver la crise
économique
voilà donc pour la riposte de l'ump et
du ps au niveau départemental des
approches différentes on l'a vu même si
les deux parties se retrouvent un pour
eux ils pensent jugé que votre programme
au niveau national entraînerait un k o
bus moi j'avais vu deux à président de
vue là exactement la même approche
incapable de parler de la france ils
parlent tous du front national je
rappelle que madame di meo du parti
socialiste plus elle s'implante à fréjus
oui il ya des leçons à david racines qui
lui a été élu puis ensuite élu sénateur
plus elle s'implante à fréjus plus son
score s'effondre donc ce qui prouve
qu'elle n'arrive pas à convaincre les
électeurs blanco leca penneteau
économise beaucoup sont parfaitement
d'accord avec nous notamment sur le
protectionnisme et la fin de l'euro
perrine ils sont quand même assez
partagés les économies du débat voilà ce
moment où la france florian philippot on
retrouve de l'attractivité est ce que
vous souhaitez toujours sortir de l'euro
comment la france retrouve de
l'attractivité elle retrouve pas dans
ses activités
les investissements étrangers sont en
transe non le nombre d'investissements a
augmenté mais je suis pourtant voilà en
termes de nombre d'emplois ça a baissé
de 14%
seul sacre et je crois 25 mille cinq
cents emplois contre 29 1000e mais comme
il s'en crée moins donc en fait
l'attractivité de la france a baissé
j'ai vu que la nouvelle agence business
france c'est ça qu'on peut trouver en
france et au passage sur les qui vont
valls aurait été mieux qu'ils vont
produire à peu près 25 milles
non mais ça c'est là c'est la commune
enfumage de business france sur aimé
qu'on garde un bon français sont été
mieux prenez en ce moment sur vous mais
bien sûr puisque la réalité c'est que
l'on baisse le nombre d'emplois comme ça
la réalité c'est qu'on investisse à
l'étranger qui revient en france en
abrégé natron de grandes sociétés à la
table de l'elysée autour de françois
hollande lundi matin oui d'accord mais
ça aussi c'est le cdh a comme moi sur ce
que je vois c'est qu'à cantu
d'investissement derrière la com
oui il ya peu dans les six noms je vous
dis en nombre d'emplois s'abaisse et
25000 emplois en avant c'est quand même
très peu pour un pays comme la france ou
65 millions d'habitants est à l'arrêt
semaine on a joué on pourrait vous dites
qu'ils reviennent donc s'avérer 602
nombre de projets oui dénombré vous
connaissez pas la valeur des projets
mais a pris à des promoteurs on voit que
c'est moins d'emplois et des prix et des
projets qui peuvent se pérennise
et après permettent de maintenir
l'emploi par exemple des rachats
d'entreprises pas forcément d'accord
voilà c'est ça aussi de maintenir aussi
dénoncer ça donc si c'est pour dépecer
l'économie française comme on l'a vu
non mais attendez l'aéroport de toulouse
pour la chine lafarge la suisse alstom
énergie les américains club med la chine
là on nous annonce dailymotion le site
français le plus visité au monde sur
internet
les chinois qui sont sûres et le
gouvernement fait rien lui laisse faire
tout savoir une encourageante puisque
monsieur macron est et rhin étaient
ravis que l'aéroport de toulouse soit
vendu aux chinois
bravo à quelques mètres et on nous a
répondu déjà sa société oui c'était
encore c'était la condition pour que les
chinois achètent des airbus s'appelle du
chantage et je ne sais pas que nous
quand nous achetons des produits ou des
marchandises aux chinois en même temps
on axait on demande on exige que des
aéroports chinois deviennent français
voyez ça ça n'existe pas les
contreparties n'existe jamais donc la
france ne profite pas aussi la
mondialisation mais non mais là bas
j'écoutais ça fait dix ans qu'on est en
supra sens non elle pourrait en profiter
si elle ça remet dans la mondialisation
parce que la mondialisation est un fait
elle pour s armer elle le fait avec
l'innovation la recherche et bien et par
exemple moi j'aimerais qu'on développe
aussi non seulement qu'on rendre la
france plus attractif pour
l'investissement étranger mais le bon
pas les rachats d'entreprises à tout va
mais vraiment productif papa quand une
usine vient véritablement implantés en
france
ça vous avez droit de faire ça vous
n'avez pas le droit de faire il ya un
état qui doit être capable un tout petit
peu défendre les intérêts nationaux
c'est vrai bien sûr et en même temps
développer l'investissement national et
pour cela il faut redonner des armes à
notre pays dans la mondialisation parce
qu'on se bat les mains derrière le dos
face à des pays qui ont des armes
par exemple ils ont larmes de leurs
monnaies c'est le 4 95% d'eau pays m'ont
autant l'euro on aura des armes donc
aujourd'hui quand l'euro baisse et je
m'en réjouis parce qu'on le demande et
ils baissent aussi pour l'allemagne donc
on retrouve aucune compétitivité par
rapport à l'allemagne alors qu'ils en
avaient des monnaies nationales
on retrouverait la compétitivité par
rapport à l'allemagne qui est quand même
de principe à faire que si on faisait du
protectionnisme il ya une fuite de
capitaux ou parce qu'ils n'ont pas
changé légalité en france aujourd'hui la
zone euro et dans la grande ligue et des
économistes pour la seule zone dans le
monde qui s'est pas remis de la crise
qui fait de la sous-croissance depuis ta
moan et unique existe c'est justement la
zone euro
il ya aussi le protectionnisme si on
pouvait de temps en temps au moins avoir
des frontières s'agit pas de les fermer
en avoir pour maîtriser la concurrence
al ce serait nous mettre à jou égales
par rapport aux autres puissances
mondiales faire du patriotisme
économique moi j'aimerais qu'on puisse
obliger l'état les collectivités les
entreprises publiques à acheter
prioritairement quand ça existe dans
l'agriculture dans l'industrie dans les
services français ou produits en france
avec le protectionnisme c'est aussi à
double tranchant c'est à dire que ça
touche aussi nos exportations
on a des sociétés en france qui exporte
mais quel rapport il les autres pays le
font le protectionnisme vous savez qu
entre 2013 et 2014 la commission open a
révélé que 170 mesures nouvelles de
protectionnisme avait été mise en place
dans le monde
j'ai pas vu que l'union européenne ou la
france prenait des mesures de rétorsion
donc nous on serait les dindons de la
farce éternelle ne pourrait jamais rien
favorable vous dites oui il pourrait ne
jamais rien faire nous par contre d
autres frais ce qu'ils veulent mais au
fond ils sont pas bêtes ils défendent
leurs intérêts leur emploi leur valeur
ajoutée puis crée de l'investissement
national pour développer dans le jus
lire les emplois et l'industrie et les
nouvelles technologies en france
en france on a une énorme épargne et le
français elle va travailler là-dessus je
pense qu'il faudrait proposer pour un
rendement rentable luxure intéressant
pour les français
d'allouer l'épargné nationale vers
l'investissement national des nouvelles
technologies les startups j'aimerais
qu'en france on soit une terre de
création d'innovation c'est déjà un peu
le cas aujourd'hui passé assez saluée
dans le monde notamment aux états unis
on a ou la filière de l'année des
nouvelles technologies est assez en
pointe et on salue beaucoup également
l'émergence en france les jeunes
formidable qu'on a encore des bonnes
écoles et des bons universités deschamps
déjà je mets des parts par les pouvoirs
publics un jeu et on a cédé oui mais en
vain cela dit ça mais c'est aussi une
question d'environnement effectivement
mais on a quand même loupé le train des
nouvelles technologies on est très peu
présent dans de grands secteurs de
l'avenir quelques uns mise à part je
veux pas dénigrer ce qui se fait on a de
bons chercheurs est dans un ingénieur et
de marié on a loupé quoi bas par exemple
on n'est pas très présent dans le
domaine de l'informatique
globalement des logiciels on n'est pas
très présent là dessus et on n'est pas
très présent on est de moins en moins
présent et je voudrais pas qu'on le soit
totalement demain dans la valorisation
de l'espace
alors qu'on a le deuxième espace
maritime du monde voilà là on devrait
très en pointe on a quand même le
deuxième espace maritime 11 millions de
kilomètres carrés derrière les etats
unis
assassin secteur on devrait investir
massivement pour l'avenir
l'union européenne la zone euro ça peut
permettre aussi de bénéficier du plan
d'investissement juncker à 115 milliards
d'euros là les startups ont sollicité
elle se bousculent elles ont toutes
déposer leur projet il y aura sans doute
8 à 10 milliards d'euros qui vont tomber
pour la france dans les secteurs par
exemple de la transition énergétique des
liaisons entre roissy et paris entre les
deux aéroports
ça c'est positif on se plaint m car
c'est du vent et je vais vous dire une
chose c'est on a repris les on a réalisé
des sauts tout mamie entreprises qui se
sont précipités pour déposer des projets
mais je comprends qu'elle affichait ses
marmailles je ferais la même chose et la
sole ou non elles sauront l'argent mais
elles ont l'argent vient d'où qui vient
pas qui n'est pas créée à bruxelles qui
vient pas de l'europe
l'argent qui vient de la france parce
que je rappelle quand même l'argent ils
tombent pas du ciel
l'argent de l'europe comment il vient il
faut quand même revenir à la pédagogie
21 milliards d'euros d' sont donnés
chaque année par l'état français au
budget l'union européenne 21 milliards
par de paris vers bruxelles pour faire
simple et reviennent en france 13
milliards donc au passage on garde 8
milliards à bruxelles on n'en reversent
en europe de l'est et en europe du sud
on n'en reversent aussi pour payer les
salaires des commissaires européens et
de l'administration et la france ne
récupère que treize dont ces plans-là
dont la pac et ses températures aux
chiffres on peut leur faire dire souvent
beaucoup de choses en un chiffre assez
vérifiées et vérifiables et facilement
d'ailleurs et 8 milliards par an
rappelle que sur un quinquennat ça fait
40 milliards car après on nous parle de
nous on cherche 150 millions là non là
c'est déjà 40 milliards d'euros qui sont
qui ne servent strictement à rien qu'ils
sont perdus par la france et les
français c'est pour ça que le plan
juncker ça me fait rire au moment
enfin ça me fait pleurer plus tôt au
moment où le commissaire en charge de
l'euro vient demander à la france 30
milliards d'euros et où manuel valls
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il va bruxelles
manuel valls quelle attitude doit il
adopter selon vous demain devant la
commission européenne un peu de fierté
cela je pense qu'il va chercher sa liste
de courses qui sera écrite en allemand
probablement d'ailleurs et il va rendre
des comptes sans doute écrite notamment
par ou en anglo-américain ses ministres
à pierre moscovici
oui c'est ça aussi mais j'ai qui donc
donnera des leçons alors que lui-même a
été incapable de redresser l'économie
française on voit bien que ce système là
il arrive en bout de course il rend non
seulement il ira chercher sa liste de
courses toutes les réformes
un épouvantable qui va devoir mettre en
place en
france 1 et on sait que dans les cartons
de bruxelles ont donc pas les minutes
d'imagination en matière de réformes
ultralibérales ça a donné la loi macron
ça donnera la macro 2 puis la loi 33
et puis il rendra des comptes parce que
bruxelles a demandé là pour les mois qui
viennent 4 milliards d'euros d'austérité
en plus ils ont déjà trouvé un c'est de
vendre des participations dans safran
une entreprise stratégique française et
qu'elle vante que nous avons critiqué
parce qu'elle se fait en dépit du bon
sens et contre les intérêts stratégiques
la france mais il s'agit de faire
plaisir à bruxelles or je rappelle que
l'austérité non seulement des primes la
croissance et l'emploi
mais en plus elle ne fait pas baisser la
dette et les déficits
elle fait augmenter la dette et les
déficits donc c'est perdant perdant
perdant
et vous êtes quand même d'accord il va
falloir faire quelques économies en
france
notre niveau de bien sûr public est
suffisamment élevée qui bien sûr
premièrement il domaine alors d'abord
une dette c'est un numérateur un
dénominateur qu'il faut regarder aussi
le pib des médiateurs donc il faut
recréer de la valeur et de la croissance
en france donc changé politique
économique c'est le lard le réarmement
dont nous parions qu'elle accroisse les
nôtres et nous voilà soulagés au pmn
aussi fait des économies
alors le salaire sur le millefeuille
territorial vous avez dit faut sauver le
département les régions et c'est aaron
touche pas si tout à fait à nous sommes
nous à la tâche et un mille feuilles
comme vous dites qu'ils soient punis ne
soit plus un mille feuilles qui sont à
trois feuilles par communes départements
et à l'état nation donc les régions aux
intercommunalités tout s'emballe l
intercommunalité à marche forcée
certainement pas notre communauté qui
crée deux cent mille emplois doublons
certainement pas non plus les régions
pas les grosses régions parce que ce
sera encore plus cher et ce sera un
lointain
j'imagine bras je pense aux français
qu'ils vivront à des centaines de
kilomètres de leur nouvelle capitale de
région des centaines faut pas exagérer
assez possible si c'est moi je serai
région alcala alsace lorraine champagne
ardenne que vous êtes en champagne
ardenne par rapport à strasbourg
nouvelle capitale vous êtes honnêtement
très loin donc vous êtes en dehors des
écrans radar forcément les régions ne
doivent pas avoir d'élus propres ce
devrait être une coordination de
départements avec une réunion des élus
départementaux régulièrement elle ne
devrait pas non plus avoir ou avoir un
minimum de compétences la proximité
revient au département le stratégik
revient à l'état et supprimer donc tous
les organismes para administratif autour
de la région par les conseils
économiques et sociaux régionaux qui
sont globalement inutiles et qui coûte
très cher et puis en face nous avons
quoi nous avons comme modèle interne
qualité région grosse région europe
l'europe fédérale supranationale ça
c'est le modèle de l'ump est ce ça n'est
pas le modèle français du modèle
républicain petite dernière qui sont je
crois qu'on arrive au terme de
l'émission à ce que vous allez faire le
ménage au niveau du parlement européen
dans les assistants parlementaires
européens ça a été pointée alors elle se
dit monsieur gens qui travaillent qui
sont rattachés au siège de votre parti
notamment à nanterre il ya aucun ménage
à faire parfaitement dans les clous
c'est pas parce que le socialiste pour
nom n'y a pas d'écran et aux courses et
monsieur schulz à huit jours des
élections député socialiste n'est rien
d'autre que cela un député allemand
socialiste schulz qui a été convoqué par
son copain valls dans sa croisade
hystérique contre le front pour lui
demander d'intervenir ou jours avant les
élections françaises
c'était quand même que les poneys une
manip entre valls au parlement personne
n'est dupe
nos assistants parlementaires ils sont
parfaitement dans les clous ils ont le
droit aussi d'être militant politique à
côté donc d'apparaître pour certains
dans un organigramme politique du front
national ça n'a rien d'extraordinaire
vegas est stricte et un bruxelles
ces règles là sont parfaitement
respectées en revanche nous avons
découvert que l'assistant à créditer de
monsieur schulz il travaillait dans une
agence de voyage du spd en allemagne le
parti allemand il a même quelques
preuves j'ai vu dans la presse allemande
maintenant monsieur donc c'est
l'arroseur arrosé
moi mon assistante accrédités elle vit à
bruxelles de travail à bruxelles ou à
strasbourg la vôtre mais d'autres fait
pas on verra la suite de cette enquête
qui a été annoncé en tous les cas même
patient une enquête en réalité on verra
merci mais les élections passées merci
monsieur viléo merci à vous merci à tous
mon soirée a très vite
oui